this morning federal regulators and
Congress are reviewing potential
whistleblower reports about the approval
process for Boeing's 737 max jet it
comes as Boeing CEO faces shareholders
and reporters for the first time since
the second deadly crash of its 737 max
in less than five months that led to the
worldwide grounding of Boeing's
best-selling plane Kris Van Cleave is in
Chicago for the Boeing shareholder
meeting Chris good morning good morning
it is six months to the day of the crash
of that first 737 max and CEO Dennis
Muhlenberg will tell shareholders that
Boeing's focus is on safety and the max
once this software update is done will
be one of the safest planes to ever fly
we'll also learn that the planes and
that software update is ready for its
final certification flight before it
goes to regulators for approval CBS News
has confirmed within hours of Ethiopian
investigators releasing their
preliminary report into the crash of
flight 302 the FAA received calls from
four potential whistleblowers the
current and former Boeing employees were
concerned about potential safety issues
surrounding the 737 max and its approval
process one of the April 5th calls
included claims of foreign object damage
to the wiring of the planes
angle-of-attack sensor those sensors
appear to malfunction on both the Lion
Air and Ethiopian Airlines max
triggering the M cache anti-stall system
believed to be a factor in both crashes
Boeing says while it cannot verify that
report safety and quality are at the
core of Boeing's values Boeing has had
issues with foreign object debris with
its kc-46
aerial refuelers and in some 787
Dreamliners in 2017 the FAA found metal
shavings in some Dreamliner's Boeing
certified as debris free richard Mester
was a technician at the 787 plant in
South Carolina he was fired last year
would you fly in a 787 today no I
wouldn't just because I don't feel like
the company's putting the priority into
quality its its production for profit
Boeing has started brainstorming with
Airlines and especially pilots about how
to restore the public's confidence
in the max when the planes are flying
again the United CEO Oscar muñoz it is a
safe aircraft we're gonna let not only
the FAA but regulators around the world
sort of declare that as well now lawyers
here in Chicago today are expected to
announce another lawsuit against Boeing
this one on behalf of the ten Canadians
killed on board Ethiopian flight 302
Norah tough to hear those details Chris
thank you